[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
the wheel of time episode five blood
calls blood this was directed by sally
richardson whitfield and written by
celine
song
as always no book spoilers in the
comments please you can only talk about
stuff from the books we've seen in the
show already but nothing in the future
please be respectful of that these
reviews i'm doing is from someone i
haven't read the books so i'm going at
this as it's just as a show and learning
the stuff as we go along so please keep
it that way really appreciate it so with
this review we'll start with the main
storyline and then we'll finish off with
what's going on with iguain and perrin
so we open with this snowy funeral right
where we left off and we're seeing
everybody mourning all the people who
are killed by logan and his army and
what i really like this episode is doing
is this worry that is happening between
lan and
moraine and that's a tribute to daniel
henny the actor of lan who really shines
this episode and as always rosamund pike
and the chemistry they have built to
earn these emotional moments but just
them acting with their faces this whole
episode was great because right from
just the scene in the beginning they're
having doubts now seeing how steppen is
and where he's at emotionally losing his
iso and that will go on throughout the
episode and what happens here is we get
a month time jump here in all stories so
that was kind of shocking to me but i
actually liked it to keep kind of moving
the story along here i like how they
wrote little character moments to learn
more about the characters here that are
subtle and not so on the nose but i
really like this moment when moraine is
telling land that her real home is this
saddle these boots this brooding man at
my side not the white tower which is
interesting and there's a line here when
they're arriving at the white tower that
land says that warders aren't supposed
to outlive their eyes to die and it you
know it kind of reminds you too that
saying like parents aren't supposed to
watch their children die and that kind
of symbolically shows here with this
relationship of a water and aniody and
again just adds to the weight that will
come at the end of this episode and what
i like about this episode is really the
episode you would think is about
stepping and what he's going through but
it's not it's really to develop this
worry that lan and moraine have in their
relationship and develop their
relationship and they also show quickly
in this scene that there's a little
moment here that moraine mentions to lan
that she should know how naive is
feeling because she's always around him
so i don't know if it's a little
jealousy a little threat there but i do
like that and it does come back around
later when steppen says to land that
naive you know clearly is falling for
you so i like that this kind of
developing this triangle a bit and it
could set up now some tension for
moraine and keeping an eye on how close
naive is getting to land so matt now and
rand get to tarvalan and this is where
they're staying to rest and clean up
before they go to the white tower and
what i did like here and how this was
just written was that matt feels
responsible for the death of this little
girl he got close to and her family at
the farm and ran says to him it was the
fade you know you wouldn't kill that
family you wouldn't hurt that little
girl but when he says that it's a
close-up on matt's face that looks very
guilty so now as the audience we see
that and go wait a minute so it wasn't
the fade who killed that family it was
matt even though he pointed out the fade
it was matt and his craziness here but
he also has a big important line saying
that tom is dead so in this month time
jump tom dies or at least we believe but
how can we even trust matt when he says
anything at this point so that's all
interesting stuff for sure and his
intriguing mystery to understand like
okay what happened to tom during this
and did he kill that family matt so i
like what they're doing there with those
two so
inevitable there's gonna always be in
fantasy shows now comparisons to game of
thrones which is the high standard of
fantasy television where i first started
really feeling this felt like game of
thrones in good ways was when moraine is
talking to naive in the white tower and
talking about the white tower and the
ice and eye and it feels a lot like
king's landing the way they talk about
it and the politics of it and that
everyone has their own agenda and to be
careful and that naive is gonna have to
become a novice here and train to be
nice to die because news is going to
spread quickly about her and her power
and that everyone's going to want a
piece of that you know prize that naive
is right that she's this powerful person
all these different colors of the ice
that i will want her and their group i
like this line maureen says too about
the icy diet where these are women that
are you know decades of training
mastering their strengths but masking
their weaknesses which i thought was
really interesting and giving all these
characters flaws which i like but i'm
also going to give a shout out to
someone who's really coming through as
an actress here which is zoe robbins who
is just incredible to me in this role of
naive because with naive she's playing
it with fear but also bravery it's a
perfect blend she's doing in her face
and she's really good with her eyes
acting which is always the key and a
moment that stood out for me it's just
her saying this line if i'm as powerful
as you say i am maybe you i said i
should be afraid of me really like that
and that gets you all so intrigued for
what's gonna happen with her character
and there's a good just theme here with
moraine trying to relate to where naive
is and that feeling of finding this
power you have realizing the source that
you touched is stronger than you will
ever be and how small it makes you feel
but you also feel bigger than the people
you love and know and where do you fit
in that weird middle you're in so i like
that moment here and the way maureen is
talking to her and saying that embrace
the gift and i will stay here i'll
protect you as best as i can and of
course when i find your friends i'll
bring them to you i just trust her less
and less as the show's going out moraine
i feel like you're supposed to and
they're doing a good job of getting you
trying to figure out moraine and like
one moment you really like her and trust
her in the other you know something else
is up and she has these secrets that
we're learning more and more about
meaning not learning about the secret
she has but that she has all these
secrets that people keep talking about
so it makes you really see this
character as a very mysterious character
which is always intriguing so we meet a
new character who seems like a lot of
comic relief here and is gonna be a fan
favorite which is this not ogre oguer
loyal it's interesting he's mentioning a
lot rand's red hair and claiming he's in
iuman i think is what he's saying i have
no idea what that is haven't read the
books but it should be important that
maybe rand's not who he exactly think he
is and we also see now that rand and
matt see this ritual they do where
they're having the ice to die go through
the streets and show this false dragon
what could happen to you if you try that
and he's just got no soul basically like
tom was alluding to what happens when
they basically gentle you the ice or die
and there's this moment where matt sees
logan and he's literally laughing at him
and is it in matt's all in matt's head
in the madness or is that really a
connection they're having and he's
seeing that in matt i i wonder and i
think it's the second the latter there
for sure but rand talks to matt and matt
wants to make a deal with rand like look
we're not letting each other get to that
level if one of us can channel period
and that will go more into that kind of
conflict there later in the episode
which we're going to get to but back to
what's happening with step in here he's
very emo as this episode goes on just
props this actor here who unfortunately
dies at the end but was a treat and
really stepped to the plate in this
episode and you know he did such a good
job of showing the emotions of steppen
get more depressed feeling the pain
more of losing his eyes to die as the
episode went on and again what it's
really serving though is what's
happening with lan and moraine's
relationship and land's character
because land's watching this man
suffering up close throughout the
episode and it is at the end of the day
scaring him and that like oh my god if i
was ever to lose moraine is this what's
going to happen to me and even when land
just mentions that to stepping about
going to his next ice to die he snaps
and he's like it's not easy just to go
from one woman to the next but this is
where you know this questionable choice
naive makes here where stefan shows up
to her looking for some sleepy time tea
we'll call it and he's talking about how
he can't sleep and she's asking like how
are you feeling are you able to at all
fall asleep and he's like just about to
drift off the pain goes away and she's
like good because i would sound normally
like a good thing but he's like no
that's the only thing i've left of her
the pain and he's like attached that i'm
not ready to let go of it and he's
hiding a bottle of booze while he's
saying this he's clearly in a really bad
state and she's like don't worry i
promise you the pain will never go away
but she still gives him this sleepy time
tea and we know she knows more about
that tea and what people could possibly
do with it because she later on tells a
story to rand about what happened with
wayne as a child and that they were
gonna give her that tea to make it easy
for her to die basically that's its main
purpose yeah to put you to sleep but
also to help ease pain of death and it's
like to me she was giving somebody the
noose here uh i don't know if she was
not really realizing what she was doing
or was she so that was interesting to me
uh and i'm sure that's going to come
back around in nineveh's character and
that we see kind of her face at the
funeral of steppen and there does seem
like a little bit of like guilt or oh my
god what have i done in there but we'll
see because maybe i'm putting a stretch
there that she was aware of what she was
actually doing but i also love a moment
here with naive where she is looking at
the statues of the warders in the past i
love that that is the production design
around the conversation that happens
when leandra and shows up to her because
we're learning about leandren and the
woman in the red and that they don't
have waters and this is what naive says
that they hate men the red and i love
she's like is that a question or a
statement leandron says and she's like
women hold the one power but men still
control much of this world men are
rarely kind to little girls who show a
spark of being greater than they are so
what i love about that line is that line
is finally getting insight into leandra
and behind this mask she always puts on
she always has a mask on but you see
we're seeing that taken off and just a
little line like that so it's really
good writing to learn more about
leandron more about the world and more
about the woman in red the iso die and
it's already showing you it's like
almost like it reminds you a little
finger from game of thrones leandren
sometimes and already just naive you
can't always protect her how moraine
wants to and just her being out in the
open like that already leandra is
getting her claws into her but literally
this is something i did not like about
the episode was bizarre was the next
scene it just jumps to loyal the o'gara
saying he has access to the white tower
and he appears with naive to rand and
matt it was bizarre it felt like a scene
was missing i did not like this this was
way too jumpy of an edit you needed
something in the middle there because we
just
literally saw naive talking to leandren
in the white tower to go to the next
scene of this okay getting her and
bringing her to matt and randa's like
whoa whoa like you need to
if you're not gonna you know show the
scene maybe when he gets naive the auger
you know you gotta have a different
scene in between of another story
something to make that not feel as
abrupt that was just not a good editing
choice at all but we see here that naive
sees obviously clearly something's wrong
with matt because when she goes to see
his tongue you know he snaps at her so
that's just going to be interesting what
happens there with matt and clearly
naive is going to have to make a choice
of what she's going to do with matt and
what she can do in her powers to help
him and it's interesting i love the
conversation here with rand and naive
and they're talking about how rand
thinks mac and channel so this goes back
to the conversation you had with matt
earlier and what you do about that and
wanting to protect matt from you know
going full crazy and possibly getting
gentled by an iso die and you know rand
is the one who's on to moraine here that
he doesn't know if they can trust her
and i like that him and naive are kind
of on the same page like we don't need
the ice to die you know like i'll hear
what i can and when guayne and parents
show up will sort the rest but i don't
know if this will go in a tragedy way of
kind of like game of thrones where your
original crew of people get separated
and they have aspirations to stick
together but things get messy right you
meet other people that have other
agendas and that's usually not what's
gonna happen but we'll see what happens
here but they're developing here to lead
into the scene with the wayne which
we'll get to about how resilient she is
and that gwain is many things but above
all house unbreakable talking about the
story where she literally had this
infection that was like breaking her
bones on herself but she didn't take
this tea and just stuck through it and
the fever went away and she stayed alive
now in this main story i like to this
leandro and moraine scene so all these
scenes are a little more talky this
episode but they're important and it's a
lot of politics stuff that the show's
showing it's going to do now which i
like because it's all interesting and
it's like you know landrieu says to
marine problem with you coming and going
when naive becomes a novice you won't be
here to guide her so that's clearly
going to be important what she's saying
there's something we're going to see a
problem here and i like the actress of
leandre and throws in this little line
too or she's like you know it's just
stressing how much naive though doesn't
trust ice to die but she mentioned she
has a certain force of will and she
thinks it will be her rules you know
that she has that red in her that's a
trait of them but moraine mentions one
thing she doesn't share with them is
their contempt for men that's the
difference so it's also just developing
again that you know these different
colors that i said i are gonna want
naive clear because she's so powerful
but who will get her and where does she
really fit but i'm gonna go with that
she doesn't fit in any of these groups
so we'll see that maybe she'll be the
one to kind of take down any corruption
in the iso die and then there's another
important scene where moraine now talks
to alana and you know moraine mentions
there's a way to release the bond
between a water and an isodi so this is
showing you what was developed in this
episode already it just looks between
moraine and land that you know maybe
this bond isn't the greatest idea maybe
this is just going to cause us extreme
hurt later on but alan's like don't do
that you know land has nothing to worry
about you're going to be okay but this
is a huge pause moraine has at this line
and she's like what have you been doing
out you know all these years alana says
to marie and she doesn't answer she
ditches the question so that's also
contributing the fear that moraine's
having that yeah i could easily maybe
die because of this risky stuff that her
and land do and she doesn't want land to
suffer like step in is and we're also
getting more information again still
interesting so i'm not bored by this is
that alana's saying that basically their
boss wants to come now answers for what
happened here with logan why they had to
gentle and she's like you were the only
one strong enough to challenge her and
this lets us know that moraine has no
designs on the seat she says i never
have but where alana really wants
moraine to be the one if there was to be
someone to be the next kind of boss of
the eyes to die is that you know
we'd rather have you than leandren
because she's getting momentum here and
not just the red are the only ones
following her she's saying other eyes to
die of different colors are as well so
this is really interesting and she even
says to again adding into the mystery of
moraine's character that one day you
have to trust someone with your secrets
and what are these secrets we don't
really know much yet so she looks into
this painting in a room too i don't know
what the deals is that that frame i'm
sure book readers do but again please
don't spoil that but there's a lot going
on here and i'm trying to process it all
as best i can not reading the books but
it's exciting me so as a tv viewer i'm
very very intrigued and this episode's
doing a good job of that it's setting up
a lot of interesting pieces as it is
also a transitional episode but
developing a lot of character and we get
more themes here where stephen now is
talking to land and i was saying before
how he brought up to land how naive is
following for her and that he sees
everything step in and lands you know
the quiet type doesn't really talk about
as much but land's like that's a bad
idea for her and stephen's like love's
always a bad idea but we still allow it
to happen or this life would be
intolerable so this is an important
theme just about the episode what the
story is kind of saying that you know
it's still worth the end of the day to
have these deep bonds even though it's
painful if something ever happens to it
but land's like well i can tolerate a
lot so he's not someone who's right in
that same mindset as step in so it's
interesting and it's gonna make you
think if he's gonna be one even to push
to moraine maybe they should separate
their bond so what's interesting here is
though stephen gave land the sleepy time
tea as well you know so he wakes up
sluggish in his deep sleep when he wakes
up then he finds the t on the counter
realizes what he has been given but he
also sees the knife is missing from the
mantle right there he's connecting oh my
god you know stefan's done something
stupid and hurt himself and he kills
himself in the statue of the room of
former waters which i like that touch
and we see this step in funeral so
important and this is really where
daniel henny brings it here as always is
rosamond pike in their connection of
what their facial expressions are saying
to each other you know and her crying
and seeing him suffer like this losing
this water and that this could happen
with us is this worth it you know and we
finally see land break now and he's
taken off his strong mask and you're
seeing the suffering has losing step in
it it's just a powerful moment and a
great moment in the episode on i loved
it i loved the ending scene here so
that's gonna bring the score way up for
me in this episode before i give my
final score and what i really think the
whole episode let's now go to the other
side of the story here with iguain and
perrin so we see the white cloaks show
up to these tankers right i love this
character of valda he just eats up the
screen he's great the actor is abdul
salus he's just killing it and he really
gets to shine this episode but we see
the tinkers are doing like this peaceful
wall because they're non-violent but
they just get beat up here this is
actually crazy scene to me and
interesting i liked it it felt different
and unique than in most shows we see how
this just kind of went about but we
don't know what happens to the tinkers
yet we just kind of see them getting
beat up by the white cloaks and they get
to capture now eguin and perrin now this
is some of the most tension we've seen
in the show yet and i loved were these
scenes where we see parent and iguane
are tied down in valdez tent now again
like i said abdul salis who's the actor
of valda he's killing it he's really
bringing this scene to the next level
and it's a great written scene and
planned out scene because it's this
tension of is she and i so die or not
and i love you gives the ultimatum like
if you're nice to die show me that you
can channel and i'll kill you and let
him go or vice versa if you don't i'll
kill him and let you go so it's like
really crazy but you get already this
reveal when he cuts paren open that he's
got these yellow eyes so he's got this
like power we don't know right but we
get a wraparound at the end that that
power is related to wolves you know
because they have the yellow eyes he
sees and that wolf wasn't gonna hurt
them and he knew that clearly because
he's got this connection to wolves so
we'll see what that's all about again
book readers i know you're chomping at
the bits to answer that question but
don't please keep that mystery alive but
i love the lines they give valda here
and he says this line idea that one
power comes from anywhere but the dark
is absurd and i love that line because
it really just explains his belief
system and and again you know that these
people in the white cloaks you know they
just believe all these powerful people
use the power it always comes from the
dark so they want to get rid of it and
that's why they hate ice to die and
women in general but i have two issues
here in these two scenes in the tent
with these three because one in the the
first incident when it's light out and
they're in the tent the score is ruining
this scene the score is abysmal here
which is unfortunate but it sets the
mood and it does not match here and it's
just cheesy sounding it's a mess and it
sucks that that's the case because it
would really be amazing scene if they
didn't have such a poor score behind it
i am also going to put madeleine madden
who plays iguain on the watch list what
i mean by that is i'm not there yet
saying she's amazing actress and i'm not
saying she's a bad actress either i'm
just saying her performance and these
sequences was questionable to me and i i
judged that by am i buying it am i
always watching and thinking someone is
that character or do i get taken out of
it watching somebody knowing they're
acting and i felt like some of this i
felt like i was watching somebody act
and that really happens here when
parents having this big moment talking
about how you know he killed his wife
and she's got these important lines like
you know one day you're gonna realize it
wasn't your fault but her facial
reactions to him saying this stuff she's
looking at the camera at one point i'm
not buying she's fully in the moment i
was thrown off by it honestly i'm a
little disappointed but that's just how
i feel again i'm not saying she's a bad
actress but i'm just saying that i felt
like the performance here wasn't great
so she's on the watchos for me of like
okay is she gonna bring it for this big
part it's to me we'll see i'm not sold
yet but we see she can channel now and
she rips parent out of him being tied up
and then he scares valda but of course
she doesn't kill him she just stabs him
which is like okay a little bit of a
rolling eye moment like why not just
kill this evil person who's just gonna
do more harm being alive but she's able
to take you know the rings of the other
ice to die that were killed by him which
is important i guess it's gonna come
around for sure and we get this reveal
about the wolf powers for parents so
it's exciting stuff and still was two
great scenes again very tense i'm
nitpicking at parts but again we want
perfection right so again the score was
really weak here and madeline madden not
sold yet but we'll see much more time to
go here but you know when i'm watching
this episode i'm watching last two
episodes i think we're really good what
it looks like to me is season one of
wheel time's gonna have it's shaky
things like i've said about cgi some of
the costumes you know and in particular
a lot of the score which has been
disappointing it doesn't really have its
own voice or sound that you want to
stick out in a show like this but this
stuff can be fixed in season two and
season three and that's usually what
happens you're gonna see stuff in season
one of the shows that seem sloppy or
weird and then it finds its footing and
it can fix those things so i think
that's kind of gonna be the case with
season one we're gonna have some stuff
where you're like oh you know but i
think if they're smart they'll work on
the stuff and can clearly be fixed and
take this show to its highest ceiling it
has that it could be amazing so i think
it could get there in a season two but
you're gonna have some stuff in season
one that feels kind of sloppy and that's
stuff that can be fixed clearly so it
gives you hope for the show in general
but i'm giving this episode an 8.8 like
i did the last episode i think it's just
as good it has a lot of more dialogue in
it less action but really important
dialogue and again every scene is
serving a purpose here which is really
good and that's what you want and it's
still not confusing which is good it's
not confusing me i thought the first
episode was a little confusing but now i
feel like i'm settled in i'm like as
someone hasn't read the books i'm
enjoying it and i'm liking the
characters and a lot of the acting's
great here so i'm excited i'm i'm in you
know and yeah it's becoming one of my
favorite shows now so let me know what
you thought of it down below again with
no book spoilers please just talking
about stuff we've already seen in the
show you can talk about from the books
but nothing in the future let me know
your thoughts so i read every comment
try to respond as many as i can and
please make sure to subscribe if you
like what i do here i really appreciate
it helps me in so many ways you have no
idea and if you love what i do i'd
really appreciate you become a member
you'll get special perks and it will
help me do this full time one day and it
will support me and help me make more
videos for you guys i'd be forever
grateful and please follow me on steve
show on twitter instagram and tick tock
for more of me and i'll see you next
time